nos piden simplificar 9 p elevado a la
dos tercios y eso dividido entre la raíz
cuadrada de 4 p kubica hagamos lo paso a
paso lo primero que podemos hacer es
aquí tenemos 9 p a la dos tercios y esto
lo puedo escribir como 9 a la dos
tercios que multiplica a p elevado a la
dos tercios este 9 p a la dos tercios lo
puedo separar de esa manera la parte de
abajo esta raíz cuadrada de 4 p cúbica
la podemos describir como 4 por p kubica
elevado a la un medio esto es lo mismo
la raíz cuadrada de 4 p kubica es
exactamente lo mismo que 4 p cúbica
elevado a la potencia un medio dado eso
podemos hacer lo mismo que hicimos aquí
en el numerador es decir esto es igual a
4 elevado a la un medio que multiplica a
p al cubo elevado a un medio que
multiplica a peu al cubo elevado a la un
medio veamos ahora cómo simplificar esto
primero el denominador esto es igual a
en el denominador tenemos 4 al un medio
que lo mismo que raíz cuadrada de 4 que
es igual a 2 que multiplica a peu al
cubo elevado al un medio que es lo mismo
que p elevado a la 3 por un medio que es
lo mismo que p elevado a la tres medios
p elevado a la tres medios ahora el
numerador nueve a la dos tercios bueno
la raíz cúbica de nueve no es nada que
puedo simplificar o lo podemos ver como
9 al cuadrado déjame hacerlo en la
siguiente manera 9 lados tercio lo
podemos simplificar como bueno no lo
vamos a simplificar pero vamos a
escribirlo de la siguiente manera que
nos va a permitir calcularlo fácilmente
9 a la dos tercios
es lo mismo que 9 al cuadrado elevado a
la potencia un tercio de acuerdo
aquí tenemos 9 elevado a la 2 por un
tercio que lo mismo que 9 elevado a la
dos tercios y esto multiplicado por p
elevado a la dos tercios y esto va a ser
igual a 9 al cuadrado es 81 81 elevado a
la potencia un tercio que multiplica a
p elevado a la potencia dos tercios y
ahora el denominador en vez de poner el
denominador como está voy a usar
exponentes negativos para expresar lo
así es que este 2 que tenemos aquí
equivale a 2 elevado a la menos 1 lo
cual equivale a un medio así es que
vamos a multiplicar por un medio este un
medio equivale a este 2 que tenemos aquí
y p elevado a la tres medios es lo mismo
que p elevado a la menos elevado a la
menos tres medios así que por lo pronto
la expresión original la hemos
simplificado en esta déjame copiar esto
y pegarlo donde sea más cómodo
trabajarlo entonces copiamos y pegamos
vamos a moverlo un poco a la izquierda
para proceder a simplificar más aún esta
expresión
veamos cómo podemos describir 81 a la un
tercio básicamente cuando elevas al cubo
bueno más bien cuando elevas a la un
tercio algo estás sacando la raíz cúbica
de si algo saquemos factores primos de
81 para ver si tenemos algunos cubos
perfectos
así es que 81 lo podemos escribir como 3
por 27 27 3 por 9 y finalmente 9 es 3
por 3
así es que 81 es tres por tres por tres
por 33 a la cuarta de tal manera que
este 81 al un tercio es equivalente
escribirlo como 3 por 3 por 33 al cubo
que va aquí y aún así multiplicarlo por
3 nuevamente esto elevado a un tercio es
lo mismo que 81 elevado a la un tercio
veamos ahora las pes y aquí estoy
haciendo más pasos de lo que haría
normalmente porque quiero que entiendas
que es lo que hay detrás de las
simplificaciones que hacemos tenemos
para la dos tercios que multiplica ap al
menos tres medios eso equivale a p
elevado a la dos tercios menos tres
medios ya sólo nos queda multiplicar por
este un medio así es que por un medio
bien
aquí es igual esto esto es igual a esto
lo podemos escribir como 3 por 3 por 3 y
por 3 lo vamos a separar como tres por
tres por tres elevado a la un tercio que
multiplica a tres elevado a la un tercio
esto lo hemos hecho ya varias veces que
multiplica a peu elevado a la dos
tercios menos tres medios esto a que es
igual
hagámoslo acá arriba como tres medios es
mayor y es negativo esto es igual a
menos tres medios menos dos tercios para
hacer esta resta sacamos como un
denominador 6 es el común denominador de
3 y 2
entonces si pasamos tres medios a sextos
esto es equivalente a 9 sextos mientras
que dos tercios equivale a 4 sextos
ahora si hacemos la resta 9 sextos menos
cuatro sextos es 5 sextos con el signo
menos que tenemos antes esto es menos 5
sextos
esto es entonces igual a p elevado al
menos 5 sextos que multiplica a un medio
que multiplica a este último término un
medio ahora tres por tres por tres a la
un tercio 27 al a un tercio la raíz
cúbica de 27 éste
así es que esto de aquí equivale a 3 que
multiplica 3 sale un tercio es la raíz
cúbica de 3
así es que esto lo podemos escribir este
término de aquí lo puedo escribir como
la raíz cúbica de 3 y luego tenemos que
a la menos 5 sextos vamos a escribirla
aquí aunque de hecho en ocasiones se
pone estos términos antes del radical
vamos a hacerlo así borremos esta raíz
cúbica de 3 para poner p a la menos 5
sextos y eso que multiplica ahora sí
vamos a poner la raíz cúbica de 3 y eso
finalmente multiplicando por un medio lo
que es equivalente a dividir entre 2
toda la expresión y ya hemos logrado una
buena simplificación aunque quizás estos
tres medios los podías poner como 1.5
que multiplica a peu a la menos 5 sextos
que multiplica a la raíz cúbica de 3 si
quieres puedes calcular la raíz cúbica
de 3 y multiplicarla por 1.5 para
obtener un número decimal x t a la menos
5 sextos y esa
la mejor simplificación que podemos
lograr